the hers on the back of my neck
literally stood up on end I was blown
away and the computer made tens of
thousands of ideas for new chemical
weapons but what that clinical
pharmacologist found was only the
beginning biocurity experts are sounding
the alarm we might be just 1 to 3 years
away from Black Death level plagues
sweeping the Earth enabled by
increasingly powerful Ai and especially
open-source AI you heard that right 1 to
3 years it sounds like science fiction
but experts aren't laughing AI is
teetering on the edge of becoming
uncontrollable I I don't think we have a
lot of time whatever we do it has to
happen fast but why are biocurity
experts so worried the inventor of
crisper genan Drive recently warned that
AI could one day create a pathogen so
deadly it could eradicate 9 in 10 humans
on Earth and this could happen in months
in 2020 covid infected roughly 50% of
Europe within 100 days now picture
everyone you know who got Co likely you
your family and well nearly everyone you
know but imagine that nine in 10 of
those people were now dead and imagine
them all perishing just 100 days 3
months after you heard about it a virus
like this could decimate Humanity far
far too fast for us to make and
distribute a vaccine AI could make it
easier to build chemical or biological
weapons terrorist groups could use AI to
spread fear and destruction on an even
greater scale one thing experts worry
about is extinction Cults like Cults who
literally want to kill everyone yes they
exist but they've never had technology
powerful enough to actually kill
everyone but AI could be just what they
need for example om Shin Rio is the
Doomsday cult that carried out the
deadly Tokyo subway nerve gas attack in
1995 killing 13 and injuring 5500 as
horrifying as that was Humanity actually
dodged a bullet because what most people
don't know is that omin Rio tried to
infect everyone on Earth with ebola
which is extremely contagious and kills
half of the people who get it imagine if
half the people you know who got covid
died from it in 1992 om Shin Rio sent a
team of 40 members to help provide Aid
during an ebola outbreak in the Congo
however their real mission was to
acquire purified samples of Ebola so
they could infect the world with it the
Cults actually recruited microbiologists
and overall spent $30 million trying to
make chemical weapons fortunately they
didn't have the technological skills
necessary to make Ebola and omin Rio
isn't the only one Isis and Al-Qaeda
also both tried to create bioweapons but
failed the recent pandemic showed how
vulnerable the world truly is to biot
terrorism bioweapons are an obvious
choice for Bad actors who want to cause
the most damage possible Isis celebrated
CO as a soldier of Allah due to its
effect on the world and a deadlier
bioweapon could kill more than any
terrorist group ever has why did these
terrorist Cults fail well it's hard to
create a deadly virus there are a lot of
steps so they try you know Googling
around but they eventually hit a wall a
straightforward extrapolation of today's
systems to those we expect to see in 2
to three years suggests a substantial
risk that AI systems will be able to
fill in all the missing pieces enabling
many more actors to carry out
large-scale biological attacks we
believe this represents a grave threat
to US National Security 2025 2026 maybe
even some chance of 2024 if we don't
have things in place that are
restraining what can be done with AI
systems we're going to have a really bad
time so why do experts worry about AI
helping terrorists here well it's simple
AI is no longer a dumb search engine
it's like having a coach sitting next to
you telling you exactly what to do
that's a game Cher I know come fu people
say oh it's like a glorified Google but
no it's not it doesn't just look up
links to websites it thinks about
questions and gives you the answer now
current AI isn't good enough to coach
terrorists through every step of making
a bioweapon but what about when AIS are
100 times or 1,000 times smarter than
they are now um and what's confusing
about AI is the same thing that knows
how to solve problems you know to help a
scientist do a breakthrough in cancer
biology or chemistry to help us Advance
material science and chemistry or do
solve climate stuff is the same
technology that can also invent a
biological weapon with that knowledge
and the system is purely aoral it'll do
anything you ask it doesn't hesitate or
think for a moment before it answers you
also the terrorists still need access to
equipment but AIS can help them with
that too as a result you won't need to
be a PhD virologist to make a deadly
virus you'll just need the newest open-
Source AI model but why do scientists
think this could happen in just 1 to 3
years consider AI art even just 1 year
ago it was a joke compared to the best
artists now in some ways AI is by far
the best artist in the world like
imagine a human going from kindergarten
finger painting to the best artist in
the world in one year AIS are not only
passing but acing all the tests we can
throw at them it's outperforming doctors
lawyers and even a faing all of our
creativity tests yeah creativity tests
so if AI can blow past us at all these
things in just a year it could plausibly
get far better at making viruses in a
year too so how exactly could AI be used
to create a pandemic if you say hey AI
how do I create a virus that ends life
on Earth and it's an open- Source model
meaning it has no safety guard rails
it'll be like sure here are some ideas
however chat GP T is supposed to refuse
to answer the problem is that chat GPT
is easy to trick MIT researchers ran an
experiment where they told some students
to try to use an AI similar to chat GPT
to create a pandemic it only took the
students just 1 hour to get the AI to
suggest Four Deadly pathogens it also
helpfully explained how to actually
generate those pathogens and it told the
students how to pull off this pandemic
without getting getting caught like it
told them how to secretly get the
equipment they needed and how to find a
shady DNA synthesis company that would
actually make their virus without asking
questions recently a company announced
they built an AI capable of not just
creating the formula for novel toxic
molecules but their AI can actually
create the molecules themselves too like
the AI generates the idea for the toxic
molecule and then they can actually go
and make it believe it or not there's an
entire field dedicated to making viruses
deadlier and more virulent called gain
of function research if that sounds like
a terrible idea well many think it is
it's supposed to give insight into how
viruses behave so that we might better
defend against them in the future but
that comes with the risk of creating
stronger viruses that might escape the
lab there have been hundreds of reported
lab leaks throughout history and it is
possible that thousands more lab leaks
have gone unreported one of the leading
theories is that Co escaped from the
Wuhan Institute of virology which was
experimenting with creating more deadly
Corona viruses if an accidental mistake
could cause a global catastrophe like Co
imagine what could happen when the next
Osama Bin Laden uses AI to create super
small poox you can also Imagine the
scenario where you say I want to kill a
million people show me a biological path
to do it these are the D
that we have to make sure are not
happening we need to put guardrails and
limits people are working on these
problems we don't fully understand the
solutions yet some AI companies like
open Ai and Google are trying to ensure
Bad actors can't use their Tech to
destroy the world but meta just straight
gives it away to anyone they claim they
do this for morally righteous reasons to
democratize the technology and so on but
a major reason they did it was because
well well they were so far behind in the
AI race see they missed the boat on AI
and they were way behind open Ai and
Google and by going the open source
route they were able to generate buzz
and help their stock price now meta says
their AI model is safe but researchers
were able to strip off the safety guard
rails in literally 2 hours for a few
hundred if you get asked a question
about how to make Anthrax it'll say I
can't I can't answer that question for
you cuz they put some safety guard rails
on it but what they won't tell you is
that you can find you can do something
called fine tuning and with $150 someone
in our team ripped off the safety
controls of that of that model and
there's no way that meta can prevent
someone from doing that despite this
meta is still planning to open- Source
their future AI models many experts
think this is extremely dangerous AI
security researcher Jeffrey Ladish said
it's like a nuclear weapon in every
household a bioweapon production
facility in every High School lab
chemical weapons too cheap to meter but
somehow worse than all of these combined
AI companies are racing to make the
strongest AI possible while knowing
they're making tools that any teenager
could potentially use to destroy
Humanity pro-op Source AI Advocates
argue that we'll use AI to defend
ourselves against pandemics but
defensive Technologies like metagenomic
sequencing and vaccines can take years
and billions millions of dollars to
scale up effectively yet a virus can
decimate Humanity in just months a good
guy with super Ebola does not stop a bad
guy with super Ebola open- sourcing AI
means irreversible proliferation once in
AI models weights are on the internet
they're out there forever anybody can
use them unlike most Industries where
leaders advocate for Less regulation
leading AI scientists are actually
advocating for more that regulatory
intervention by governments will be
critical to mitigate the risks of
increasingly powerful models they know
this technology can go horribly wrong
amade pleading with Congress for more
regulation is reminiscent of
oppenheimer's actions after he developed
the atomic bomb just days after the
devastation of Hiroshima in Nagasaki
Oppenheimer begged the Secretary of War
to ban nuclear weapons I feel that I
have blood on my hands after after World
War II countries stockpiled nuclear
bombs for
decades but suddenly in the 1980s the
countries of the world came together to
start voluntarily dismantling their
nuclear weapon stockpiles how did this
happen the movie The Day After was
broadcast to a 100 million Americans
literally half of the country watched it
it showed the absolute devastation and
Terror of nuclear war the film was so
eye openening it even turned turned the
Joint Chiefs of Staff to Stone a nuclear
war cannot be won and must never be
fought the film changed the world and
led to two historic nuclear disarmament
treaties just look how many nuclear
weapons there were compared to now some
say well nuclear nonproliferation failed
because there are still nine countries
with nukes and that's true but nine is a
lot less than 200 nukes are super scary
but nukes don't make nukes better nukes
don't invent better nukes nukes don't
think for themselves and say I can self
improve what a nuk AI does like AI can
make AI better in fact and this isn't
hypothetical Nvidia is already using AI
to help design their next generation of
chips in fact those chips have already
shipped safety isn't just a priority
until we as a society decide that it is
AI is getting so dangerous that two
former touring Awards winners which is
basically the Nobel Prize of AI recently
said they actually regret their life's
work which is a really serious thing to
say Jeffrey Hinton also quit his
prestigious highly paid job at Google to
warn the world about AI that takes
serious courage imagine being praised as
a Godfather of your field and then after
20 years being hit by the sudden
realization that your technology could
be the worst thing to ever happen to
humanity right now there's more
regulation on selling a sandwich than
building Godlike AI do we need to wait
for the Hiroshima in Nagasaki equivalent
of AI biot terrorism before we take
action remember experts think this could
be just 1 to 3 years away a handful of
corporations are racing to develop a
button that could potentially destroy
Humanity as we know it few people are
capable of creating super viruses now
but soon many more will be able to
if thousands of people have their finger
on a button to end the world should we
be willing to bet that someone won't
push it